you know what you look very handsome
by the way this is my gesture
for particularly women
oh just when you see them and you're
like
and this is like it's the shut the uh
compliment you know how to shut the up
can be a real compliment so it's like
this but it's like
talk about this nude illusion yes tell
us about it illusion is giving
things so my Dolce Gabbana dress which
came to me two days ago uh kind of a
surprise I decided to dress like an
Oscar in case I don't win one I'm going
to see a picture of me looking like one
I have to have this why did you wait
until two days before there was a you
know there was a dress and then there
wasn't a dress and I'm relaxed and easy
with it all and Dolce who I've worn a
couple times
they have a beautiful team of
seamstresses that whip this up in a
couple days and
voila no one has enjoyed this run more
than you from Palm Springs when you were
in the back eating to and hanging to now
how much fun is because it's been fun
for I want to tell you it's been fun
you've made it fun for us we are happy
to see you it's been great
this is the best part of this industry
these kind of celebrations celebrating
movies celebrating the fact that we get
to go to movies again in theaters all of
it is the good stuff the hard stuff for
the 4 a.m calls and the 16-hour days in
the rain in the dark running around
if this isn't Fun and joyful if I can't
celebrate 64 years
50 years 46 years as an actor and enjoy
that I'm going to the Oscars that I'm
talking about a movie about love and
family and kindness and reunification
with this gorgeous group of people if
I'm not going to enjoy that then I don't
know what there is to enjoy and I'm
sorry if people feel and I don't know
who we're speaking of that this is too
serious for them that they take it too
seriously
it's in award show there are those folks
though Jamie I do understand
me and I'll Mommy will give them a just
a slight adjustment
that's what I'm talking about we know
you like to kiss folks so if we hear
everything everywhere all at once can we
see
slips can we see it happen are you
planning on kissing me you know what I
don't plan things I don't I'm not
someone who thinks about anything in
advance I live very in the moment very
here with y'all and what you know Que
Sera Sera whatever will be will be the
Futures not ours to see Que Sera Sera
Somebody by the way kiss you on a cheek
I see it right there there's a little
yeah a little lipstick left over
listen she's beautiful I've loved her
come on there we go listen this goes to
the record books listen I'm the guy from
Perth who watched perfect and was like
everything is different now what she
talks about perfect and
yeah
I mean I can't even with you did you
bring your husband your mom was
nominated in 1961 yes oh
what does that mean to you well they
were both nominated for Oscars my
parents
um and uh same category my mom yeah you
know obviously they're on my mind very
much so on my mind and in my heart and
um as is my family my friends my friend
group I have a big friend group I'm I'm
feeling very warm and it's not because
I'm
schmitzy it's I feel very warm and very
the the Goodwill of my friends and
family has been lovely
being a protein bar in his seat so you
got it good I got him here foreign
[Music]